Percy a question for you you are
Veronica's best friend and in this weird
way you have a best friend kind of
front-row seat to her love life and her
sex life and that kind of I mean talk
about that a little bit well : I got the
script at home I opened it up and I had
a real door at the moment I was like
we're a healthy sex life
this new reboot you guys which i think
is a wonderful thing to show and don't
like but you're there you're there like
there's a scene where you're practically
like watching this oh yeah it's a dream
sequence and I'm sitting in the corner
while this is in the corner sucks in the
corner while Veronica desert oh I mean
it's a dream so it's not just this is it
what's that like for you you're sitting
there and you're you're watching this
happened with these two actors that you
know really well I gave myself a pep
talk in the trailer and I said look man
just don't make this weird for your
friends the scene we walked out turning
around putting camera on me and that's
the first time I met genuine eye contact
with Kristen and she says Percy this is
my job don't judge me
yeah yeah yeah a fascinating friend it
would sit there for that